foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 191 indeed
I'm Dr Brett Weinstein your Dr Heather
Hein we're feeling pretty primed today
I uh was gonna gloss over that question
because I hadn't thought carefully about
it but um at least an odd number so yes
indeed gloss gloss I was in uh
glossophagine bats as well as in the
root meaning tongue gloss over it yeah
I'm not sure what this has to do with
glossophaging bets but I'm thrilled that
it does because glossophagine bats are
really spectacular creatures these are
nectariverus bats you should be careful
to pronounce that nectariverse because
if you say nectivorous it means they eat
neckties which they do not no they've
used famously low in nutrients neckties
and hard to digest hard to digest I
think is the uh the primary issue
they're high in nutrients especially if
they haven't been washed in a while
let's put it this way given the strength
to weight ratio of silk in high quality
neckties well sure I mean if you're
going to wear a necktie you know go
bigger you're talking about wearing I'm
talking about eating
it's a fair point but nonetheless it
seems to me there must be a higher
abundance of uh cheap synthetic neckties
in the world than in fancy still connect
eyes I'm actually not sure that that's
true because it's the kind of thing that
if you're gonna wear one you're gonna
wear one and if you're gonna wear a
cheapo you're probably not going to wear
anything unless you work in the mail
room and it's a clip-on but I don't know
how common clip-ons even are these days
but the point is I don't know I'm way up
you were talking like men's fashion and
you you seem certain like I am out I
don't know the strength to weight ratio
of silk is so high
that I would imagine the energy in the
bonds contained therein is uh something
to behold so well I imagine the nectarus
as opposed to the nectar river is bats
that eat neckties have the digestive
enzymes perhaps even the salivary
enzymes necessary to deal with those
bonds that you have extrapolated from
the strength to weight ratio of silk
given that those bats are entirely
hypothetical icy no reason they wouldn't
have those enzymes absolutely yeah
excellent all right now that we have
alienated virtually everyone
um we can get on with the uh podcast
it's live stream 191 it's Prime uh it's
pretty cool join us on Rumble please uh
And subscribe to our channel here join
the watch party that's happening right
now on locals for members locals only
live conversation we got lots of stuff
going on at locals we encourage you
strongly to join us by subscribing for
free on Rumble and you can join us for
free on locals as well but we really
appreciate people joining as members and
you get amas with Brett early release of
guest episodes of Dark Horse you get our
private monthly q a uh soon uh ask us
the Discord server lots and lots of good
stuff there today we're going to talk
about climate and mother nature and
libraries in Canada and uh and other
things mostly a lot a lot on climate
that we're gonna we're gonna start
talking about climate climate but the
tendrils it turns out go everywhere yes
of course they do yeah of course they do
uh so we will not be doing a q a today
and next week we're coming to you a
little bit late we'll be back uh I think
3 30 uh Pacific next week and we're
going to move the rest of all the things
we want to talk to you about until the
end except for our sponsor which as
always we have chosen carefully we
really do truly vouch for so if you are
interested in supporting the podcast
another way and are interested in Arma
paleo Valley or uncruise please listen
to our ads and uh and use the um
promo codes like what uh promo codes uh
that uh that our sponsors offer us okay
so our first our first sponsor this week
is amra it's brand new to us in one way
but completely ancient in another it's
Arbor armor is colostrum
colostrum is the first food that every
mammal eats produced in the first two or
three days of an infant's life and is
nutritionally different from the milk
that comes in afterwards mammals have
existed for 300 million years give or
take a few tens of millions of years and
the first food that every mammal has
eaten is colostrum colostrum serves many
vital functions including that of
protecting and strengthening the mucosal
barriers of infants before their own
barriers mature
modern living breaks down near me
Coastal and immune barriers as we all
know and armor is the superfood that
builds it back armor colostrum protects
and strengthens your body's barriers
creating a seal that guards against
inflammation and everyday toxins
pollutants and threats armor uses their
cold chain biopoton technology to
concentrate colostrum's 400 plus living
nutrients into their most pure and
bioavailable form
according to a review published in the
journal clinical nutrition open science
in 2022 bovine colostrum has been used
to treat cancer AIDS polio heart disease
and rheumatoid arthritis it is a general
anti-inflammatory and its use in adults
is known to increase lean muscle mass
improve athletic performance and
recovery time support healthy digestion
and reduce allergy symptoms
armor starts with sustainably sourced
colostrum from grass-fed cows from their
Co-op of dairy farms in the U.S and they
Source only the Surplus Surplus
colostrum after calves are fully fed
unlike most colostrums which use heat
pasteurization that depletes nutrient
potency armor uses their cold chain
biopoton technology an Innovative
process that purifies and preserves the
Integrity of hundreds of bioactive
nutrients while removing cassine and fat
to guarantee the highest potency and
bioavailability of any colostrum
available on the market the quality
control is far above industry standards
including being certified to be
glyphosate free
I went into the research literature a
little bit to figure out what what we
think we know what western science
thinks it knows about colostrum and sure
enough as is included in that 2022 paper
I just referenced there is much that is
already understood about about
colostrum's benefits and a lot more
promising and I will say that when I
have started I have started eating this
and it does show for me many of the
positive effects that we are hearing
about in this research
benefits of Armor's colostrum also
include clearing of blemishes shinier
thicker hair stabilization of blood
sugar levels and acceleration of fat
burning and colostrum has been shown to
significantly improve Fitness endurance
and significantly decreased recovery
time after intense exercise so armra
that's a-r-a nope that's Arma armra as a
special offer for the Dark Horse
audience receive 15 off your first order
go to tryarmara.com Darkhorse or enter
Dark Horse to get 15 off your first
order that's try
armra.com slash Dark Horse it's so
strange being a mammal it is is a very
bizarre thing being a mammal indeed but
when um
when Nature reveals to you things uh
that those who produce it would uh are
intending as food consider that as food
yes I would also say
um you know as you know sometimes before
I uh go on stage at a public event I
have a little ritual I do where I say to
myself don't this up and and I'm
thinking that that actually I don't
think I do that you don't know that no
no that's what I do and if I'm going on
stage with someone
um and they ask me what they should be
thinking I tell them don't it up
um it probably doesn't help that no no
it's it's exactly the thing that you
need to hear
um but I imagine hearing it from
yourself is rather different from
hearing it from someone else oh yeah
it's got to be alarming but it just it
it puts you in the right frame of mind
but anyway the point is it's also good
life advice you know medicine time and
time again technology take something
that works great and then thinking it's
going to improve it it it up so
returning to a natural approach is uh is
a key a key takeaway from that yeah
armors armor is great stuff
okay our second sponsor this week is
Paleo Valley paleo Valley makes a huge
range of products from supplements like
fishrow and organ complex grass-fed bone
broth protein and superfood bars
everything we've tried from them has
been terrific including their golden
milk made with loads of turmeric but
today we're going to talk once again
about their beef sticks the beef in
these delicious snacks comes from small
American-owned Farms that practice
rotational grazing paleo Valley's beef
sticks are 100 grass-fed and finished
entirely organic and naturally fermented
100 grass-fed beef is more nutritious
than grain-fed beef in many ways
including that it contains more calcium
magnesium potassium zinc phosphorus
beta-carotene and iron and it's also
utterly delicious if you're thinking
that paleo Valley's beef slicks sticks
are like Slim Jims you're wrong for one
thing unlike Slim Jims paleo Valley beef
sticks contain no mechanically separated
chicken parts
for another paleo Valley's beef sticks
are actually good for you see earlier
point but not including mechanically
separated chicken parts ingredients
hiding in most beef sticks and jerky
include MSG hormones hydrogenated oils
and brominated vegetable oil which if
you're wondering what that is it was
first patented as a flame retardant and
now it's in a lot of food not if you buy
paleo valley though furthermore unlike
other meat snacks paleo Valley uses
natural fermentation to preserve its
beef sticks this gives the beef sticks a
long shelf life without the use of
harmful acids and chemicals and with the
added benefit of contributing to a
healthy gut
paleo Valley beefsticks are also keto
friendly and make a great protein Rich
snack to grab when you're on the go like
running out the door for a meeting or
going on a bike ride
paleo Valley does not cut Corners they
Source only the highest quality
ingredients and are passionate not only
about human health but environmental
restoration Animal Welfare as well and
they're a family-owned company tripelia
valleys beef beef sticks today you'll be
so glad that you did I think they're
completely delicious I love these things
head over to paleoballey.com that's
p-a-l-e-o-v-a-l-l-e-y.com slash
Darkhorse for 15 off your first order
I think you may have innovated a slogan
for them what's that try paleo Valley's
beef sticks and not those other guys
beef slicks
all right I think I think you wouldn't
visit that not me but
all right uh our final sponsor this week
is uncruise small ship Adventures
on cruise explorers by sea and by land
they have boats that hold orders of
magnitude fewer people than most cruise
boats and you won't miss them their
passengers are awesome but there are
fewer of them they take them to some of
the world's most magnificent places
Panama and Costa Rica Galapagos the Sea
of Cortez in Mexico Alaska even our own
backyard the San Juan Islands when
uncrews first approached us we were
skeptical
our standards for travel are especially
high
and we have years of experience leading
trips to the scablands of Eastern
Washington and the Columbia River Gorge
as well as the Andean paramo Galapagos
and the Amazon we know that most trips
do not meet Expectations uncruised by
contrast exceeds expectations the small
boats of uncrews allow passengers to get
real deep experience their largest boat
can accommodate a mere 86 guests the
boats of uncruise take small groups of
people to places that larger boats can't
go and the excursions are designed to
bring people into deep nature without
destroying it when we spoke with the CEO
Dan Blanchard we discovered a shared
ethos the value of wild roadless nature
for exploration and observation
we took an uncrewed week-long trip
through the Inland Waters of Southeast
Alaska in early May and were blown away
by what we saw and what we were able to
do we saw sea otters with their pups
mountain goats Eagles in their nests
brown and black bears puffins orcas
humpbacks Arctic turns too many species
to list really and mile after mile of
the most breathtaking scenery each day
we got off the boat to hike or kayak and
the crew and naturalist guides were to a
person kind knowledgeable and
enthusiastic the food was surprisingly
good as well and food preferences and
sensitivities were handled perfectly and
every sailing with on cruise is
all-inclusive Transportation drinks Farm
to Table Cuisine daily excursions
everything is included on cruise
understands that the boat is just a tool
their small ship cruises take guests
through communities and locales on the
ground so that they can have actual
experiences
and uncruise is giving Dark Horse
listeners a fantastic deal five hundred
dollars off their current cruises an
offer that you can combine with other
savings so start planning your next trip
with uncrews today and take advantage of
this great offer go now to uncruise.com
Pages slash Darkhorse remember to save
500 on your trip and go now to
uncrews.com Pages slash Darkhorse again
that's uncrews.com Pages slash Darkhorse
all right
so
today we're going to start by talking a
bit about climate
excellent a a fraught topic no matter
which direction you approach it from
always brought at this at this point uh
and
um
maybe we should just I'm not I'm not
sure actually the right the right
approach here because you know we have
we have talked a bit uh many times about
uh what we understand to be true and
what we understand to be uncertain
about uh climate change and uh and the
models that are used to generate uh what
we are told by many are
um
our consensus right in the scientific
community and in part uh what is
absolutely true is that
um models
requiring that is that assumptions be
made about what you wait and what you
don't wait and what you think is
important and which data sets you use
and and such
inherently will spit out conclusions
that are consistent with the assumptions
that you fed into the models this is
just a fact of using models and so
um it is
alarming frankly uh that we can be
assured
that there is nearly complete consensus
across all scientists
of the conclusions of the climate change
models given that it is models that
we're talking about like any time and
you know if if you didn't know this
already about science kovid should have
revealed this anytime you are told
follow the science do the thing that all
the scientists know is right there is a
really good chance that there is some
obfuscation going on that that's not
that's not how science works right you
have you have something to add here
well I'm debating whether or not to add
it here but
um
I don't want to derail you so why don't
you continue and I will I will introduce
this piece shortly okay
so
um
there are a couple new papers out
um both from a group called series
c-e-r-e-s
a research group um based on the east
coast of the United States which I'll
talk about a little bit as well after we
talk about the science
um and in fact they you know the group
itself
um put out this blog post on their on
their site which you can just show
briefly here Zach new studies suggest
global warming could be mostly an urban
problem
a new study published in the scientific
peer-reviewed journal climate by 37
researchers from 18 countries
suggest that current estimates of global
warm air contaminated by Urban warming
biases the study also suggests the solar
activity estimates considered in the
most recent reports by the un's
intergovernmental panel on climate
change that's the ipcc likely
underestimated the role of the Sun in
global warning warming since the 19th
century okay so that's the that's the
proceed that's that's the very short
version of what um these researchers
claim to have found
um and there are again two papers one of
them is still in uh pre-print and one of
them in the journal climate has been
published and I want to spend a little
bit of time talking about the journal
the paper that's been published in the
journal climate
um
Let's uh let's just go to this is a PDF
of the paper again you can show my
screen here the detection and
attribution of northern hemisphere land
surface warming from 1850 to 2018 in
terms of human and Natural Factors
challenges of inadequate data okay it's
one of these papers with a ton a ton of
authors uh the first three in the author
list being uh the prime uh drivers
behind the series uh Institute and
there's a whole bunch of other
researchers from across um institutions
around the world including some
independent researchers so from the
abstract of this paper we have a
statistical analysis was applied to
Northern Hemisphere land surface
temperatures from 1850 to 2018. to try
to identify the main drivers of The
observed warming since the mid-19th
century
I'm just I'm going to keep on stepping
out for editorializing no one is
suggesting that we haven't been warming
since we started taking data in the mid
19th century
two different temperature estimates were
considered a rural urban blend that
matches almost exactly with most current
estimates and a rural only estimate
the rural and urban blend indicates a
long-term warming of 0.89 degrees
Celsius per Century since 1850 while the
rural only indicates 0.55 degrees Cent
Celsius per century
this contradicts a common assumption
that current thermometer-based Global
temperature indices are relatively
unaffected by Urban warming biases
okay let's just let's just stick to that
one for the moment if you were giving my
screen back
um
so
and that's that's sort of half of what
this paper is is doing
um
it's well recognized that cities are
hotter than surrounding areas we know
some of the reasons for this maybe maybe
we actually have a really good fix on
all of the reasons but
um you know higher density lots of black
surfaces that reflect uh you know Albedo
is is not our friend in cities things
like this right so they absorb energy
from the sun because they're black if
you think about cities yeah if you think
about an air conditioner an air
conditioner cools a room but it creates
more heat the net output is heat that
heat ends up in the city right cities
yes buildings and cities are cooler
maybe cooler than the surrounding
Countryside but the air outside in
cities will therefore be hotter
therefore be hotter and obviously
they're not measuring uh the temperature
inside of apartments they're measuring
it outside if you think about the
canyonizing effect of buildings they
will prevent that heat from dissipating
at any normal rate boundary layers being
what they are boundary layers being what
they are so these are reason oh you know
and think about every car going down the
highway is putting out hot gases even a
car that isn't putting out hot gas I
said every car it's not quite every car
because we've got electric cars in which
the heat that is uh produced by the
generating of the energy if it's let's
say Coal Power that's producing the
electricity is elsewhere but nonetheless
the car is moving air molecules it's
literally warming the air as it moves
the tires are creating heat so all of
these things are generating heat and it
will be concentrated where human
activity is concentrated and we call
that thing a city and this is in
is not controversial for anyone like
like completely well understood and
demonstrably true that cities are harder
than surrounding areas urban areas are
harder than rural areas we know this but
Urban heat the fact of urban areas being
hotter than rural areas has been
dismissed uh by mainstream climate
scientists as trivial and contributing
to our understanding of uh of a warming
climate
um
on what basis it's been dismissed I
don't I don't even know right because
what this research and and presumably
someone does but what this research that
we're talking about now that was just
published in the journal climate uh I
think it was at the very end of August
of 2023
and these researchers look at
temperature estimates only from rural
areas
rather than from the urban rural mix
that pretty much all of the other models
are looking at they find that 40 percent
of the warming since 1850 is
attributable to Urban Heat
now that's a not all of it and B that's
not nothing because we still have a
problem where cities are hot and they're
getting hotter
um this so you know this still is a
significant fraction of warming to be
explained and cities being hot is a
problem for a number of reasons but it
does suggest that rural areas are not
warming at the rate that we have been
told the entire Globe is warming because
uh what you what you have uh is
um is a lot of data being taken from
urban areas
so I want to interject something here go
for it
it is true that cities are warming and
that that's a real phenomenon it is
false to the extent that any pattern of
climate change is deduced based on
City warming that is false
um it is a little bit like
um the conditions in an apartment uh if
you took data from inside the oven
you might get an alarmist picture of the
conditions inside the apartment it is
not that the oven isn't real it's not
that it's not generating heat in the
case of an oven and on an interior wall
in an apartment it's not even that all
that heat doesn't ultimately end up in
the apartment it does but dissipated
over a very large volume it's not a
critical matter and so the the old
ultimate underlying question here is how
critical is what we face and to the
extent that it is critical what is its
source
yeah so here's um a bit from uh Pages
nine and ten of the paper with regard to
this particular
set of results that they've got in this
study we proceed with the two
temperature series described above that
is the urban Andro like all all of the
all of the temperatures uh since 1850
through 2018 and
um just the just the rural areas which
is a tiny fraction it's only it's only
14 of all of the temperature stations so
we got all of it versus 14 but the 14
are those which are in rural areas
a visual comparison I'll show you the
visual comparison after I read through
this
um a visual comparison of the two series
shows that while there are clear
similarities between the rural and urban
and Rural only estimates there are also
several key differences and they
identify three one the rural only
estimate is noticeably noisier I.E the
magnitudes of the fluctuations from year
to year are larger this is largely a
consequence of the reduced number of
stations however it is noteworthy that
the timing of the multi-decatal warming
and cooling periods for both series are
qualitatively smaller so with regard to
this first point about greater noisiness
in the data this will always be true
when you have a data set that's smaller
the larger your data set the lower the
impact of noise of outliers of
fluctuations that will happen in terms
of your ability to actually read and
interpret the data set so this is the
reason that the
um
the scientific the pseudo-scientific
religion that Embraces randomized
controlled trials as the only source of
reliable information this is the point
that they are actually not wrong about
that large data sets drive out noise so
you can see subtle patterns
um so anyway that that is why we call it
the more subtle the actual pattern
the more likely a small data set is to
obscure that subtle pattern by virtue of
the fact that there will be noise that
will overwhelm uh subtlety and just for
the sake of completeness um when we used
to teach signal to noise ratios as
professors it is important to understand
that noise is not a an actual phenomenon
noise is the sum total of the effects of
all of the things that you're not trying
to study yeah so it shows up as some
random influence or maybe a systematic
influence right and I mean it's not
sometimes there will be error in data
and data collection right but um but you
know climate and weather are understood
to be different things linked for sure
related for sure but at different time
scales and so if what you're trying to
figure out is is there a longitudinal
pattern longitudinal just referring to
you know long there is the time uh
Dimension right so if you're what you're
trying to figure out is is there a
pattern over 150 200 years
the fact that in 1910s such and such had
a really hot summer and a really cold
winter is not relevant you know the
people living then will have felt like
oh my God this feels like the end of
everything but it doesn't it doesn't
necessarily play into the the long
um the longitudinal data so let me let
me give a different example that will
illustrate the noise Point Let's suppose
that you were trying to study the change
in uh in
um
symptoms associated with a virus across
time and so you were looking at data
sets but you had a population that
wasn't totally genetically homogeneous
you had people from one uh
origin living in one part of your sample
area and people of another extraction
living somewhere else the genetic
differences between those people is
something that you didn't measure and
maybe didn't even think about but to the
extent that it can affect how a virus
impacts people for example you know
covet had a bias with respect to blood
type right to the extent that blood
types are not perfectly evenly
distributed across the population if you
sampled in such a way that you happen to
capture more people with O positive
blood in one part of your sample it
would show up as noise relative to the
actual pattern you were trying to study
which is how virulent is this particular
variant of the virus but one
experiment's noise is a one scientist's
noise another scientist's hypothesis and
so you can look at data sets that appear
to be very noisy with regard to
something and say you know well you know
let's dig there let's figure out what
what what there is to be explained there
potentially and actually this year the
what you're pointing to is the perfect
example of this because in effect if
you're asking the question you know what
is the temperature doing over time and
you are not thinking about what is the
population doing over time oh it's
concentrating heat in these little
places where we also tend to measure
temperature and the point is it's noise
until you decide to study that impact
and then you discover oh actually one of
the factors that was influencing what we
thought was going on with climate is
actually urbanization right
okay so again here we are in in the
middle of this paper talking they are
talking about three
um Bindings that they get when they
compare the urban and rural uh data sets
uh data set uh from 1850 to 2018 to the
rural only we talked about noise number
two is the long-term linear warming
trend of the rural and urban series is
62 percent higher than that for the
rural only series
uh and we've already gone over the
numbers
um this paper published in 2021 by the
same authors of this paper many of the
same authors argue that much of this
extra warming in the rural and urban
series is due to a combination of
urbanization bias and urban blending
arising from the homogenization process
so we've already sort of covered much of
that and then three
while the rural and urban series implies
an almost continuous long-term warming
the rural only series suggesting much
more non-linear Behavior
that is the rural only series suggests
that temperatures have alternated
between multi-decadal periods of cooling
and periods of warming since at least
the mid 19th century if I can have my
screen back just for a minute to find
the um find the relative relevant thing
here yeah here it is
um I might is this going to all fit um
yeah that shows okay so this is uh I
think figure 3A from the same paper
um soon at all 2023 uh published in
climate this last month this is their um
this is the visual accompanying what we
were just talking about the comparison
of rural and urban with rural only
estimates where the rural and urban
which is what you what you will tend to
hear about in most uh climate change
models and what we are told there is
nearly complete consensus about from
climate scientists is in red the the
non-dashed line in red for those of you
with color inferiority
um and the um
and the data that these authors are
using which is again is a tiny subset of
the data that are that are used
um generally but what they have selected
out is uh the urban
um the the urban places so the rural
only data with a blue dashed line shows
uh again it's it's noisier your Peaks
and your troughs are higher that's
that's the noise but also not with
regard to noise but with regard to
um the non-linearity the less linear
nature of the change the red line is
more or less going up over time the blue
dashed line using data only from the
rural uh the the rural temperature
stations it does a lot more going up and
down
that said beginning in about 1970 we see
what looks to me and I'm not I'm not
doing the math on this they do they do
some of it later in the paper but I
don't remember whether they say 1970
looks like an inflection point uh with
regard to either model right
so
um so urbanization bias uh in the
standard ways that we are informed about
climate change
yes
does that mean that there is nothing to
be found in uh in an assessment that the
globe is warming no
but is there a number is is there bias
in what we are being told and is there a
pattern that is being obscured by using
data um from from places that really it
shouldn't be used and here's here's one
more reason that we probably should be
that we absolutely I'm just gonna say
absolutely should be suspect about using
these Urban uh weather stations these
Urban temperature stations is that we've
got data here from 1850 now not all of
these weather stations have been in use
since 1850 of course but many of them
were and have been in continuous use
since then
so many of those that are Urban now were
Urban in 1850. all right so what you're
going to find is a warming Trend
regardless because they went from rural
to Urban and we know that cities are
hotter and so even within a temperature
station if you have urbanization around
that temperature station you will get a
warming Trend no matter what is
happening more globally
yeah
um all right now how to put some of
these things together one as I mentioned
to you when you first pointed this paper
out to me
this result did not come as a total
shock because I had a conversation with
Creon Levitt former NASA scientist on
this very topic based on different data
and this is not a this is not a public
conversation it was not a public
conversation he does have a he's written
up what he was looking at and I will put
a link in the description or I will give
it to you and you will put a link in the
description since you compile those
things
um but anyway he wrote up his analysis
and what he looked at
on the basis that the data sets that are
traditionally used for calculating
warming are understood widely by people
who are skeptical to have a lot of
monkey business in them that there's a
lot of adjustment in things that is not
necessarily Justified uh by rigorous
scientific logic and so he looked for a
data set the the modelers will say
there's we always we always manipulate
things and you know manipulate will be a
wrong word but like but um but you're
saying actually it's widely understood
that this level of tinkering does is not
justified by their explanations for why
they're doing it right so let's give an
example of why
um tinkering might actually be justified
let's suppose
that you were collecting uh temperature
data from a bunch of sensors that you
had distributed around some landscape
let's suppose it had nothing to do with
global warming we were just measuring
temperature because you were interested
in some ecological phenomenon phenology
the knowledge when yes you know does is
related to climate of course but um you
know when when do plants in a particular
when when do deciduous huckleberries
flower every year
um in you know in the Pacific Northwest
right so maybe you would be related to
temperature you'd be looking at
microclimates you would have distributed
a bunch of sensors and then you would
take their data and you would correlate
uh that data with measurements that you
took some other way about what was
flowering
okay so suppose uh on some day you know
you get an average temperature of
Fahrenheit let's say it's 75 degrees
um but one sensor reads zero
okay that sensor is broken
if you include the zero your data set is
worse than if you exclude it you have a
totally legitimate reason to throw it
out you know it wasn't zero yeah um so
that would be an obvious case now you
could also do other things what if it
says 58.
right and everyone else all the other
sensors are in the mid 70s right so you
could throw out the outliers that are
far enough out that they're suspect and
you know based on what what it was you
were studying you would have to be
careful not to throw out data that's
actually informative but but I mean this
is always so I know you were going
somewhere specifically but this is
always the problem with throwing out
outliers that you say well okay zero
that's broken yep right uh 200 degrees
Fahrenheit that's broken like that you
know those are broken yeah but within
say three standard deviations of the
norm
that's broken Maybe
but if you start whittling away the
outliers until what you get is an answer
that looks right to you what looks right
to you starts to become a much more
narrow field and you yourself as a
scientist become canalized and then your
data become catalyzed and then you can
only see one thing and you're no longer
operating as a scientist yeah in fact
we've mentioned this before but there's
a marvelous
exploration of this and related topics
by Feynman called cargo cult science and
he talks about the fact that very
important scientific discoveries have
been uh delayed by the fact that people
were throwing out the evidence that they
were true because it violated their
assumptions about what was possible
um so I can't remember if
Maxwell's equation I don't remember what
the exact example was but anyway it's
well worth looking at this because the
point is on the one hand in order to do
good science sometimes you got to throw
stuff out right on the other hand you
can certainly talk yourself into
validating a false belief so this has to
be done by people who are scientifically
rigorous and know when to be surprised
and know when to just throw something
out because it couldn't possibly be
right
um
so anyway those uh those are important
influences now what Creon did and again
we will put the link to this in in the
description here but what Creon did was
he looked at a different data set that
was largely ignored and therefore hadn't
been tinkered with and the data set has
to do with the measurements of
temperature and other parameters at
airports where these things are
rigorously monitored because they are
relevant to Aviation you know you can
you know an extreme case you can think
about the likelihood that there is ice
on the wing of an airplane can is a life
and death thing and so there's a there's
a whole system for monitoring these
parameters
so Pilots know exactly what's going on
and what Creon found
very much consistent with this paper but
maybe even more extreme is that with
this paper that I'm talking about soon
at all 2023
um was that in places he compared for
example after uh
talking to me or thinking about our
podcast he looked at Portland and found
uh warming and then he looked at is it
Camp Pendleton
um but a
an airport that had no development
around it and he found that the warming
that he indeed saw in the Portland
measurements evaporated when or probably
evaporated of course there's noise in
both data sets but appears to have
evaporated when he looked at a uh what
should have been a climatologically
similar location that had not
experienced the development over the
same period of time so anyway this is
exactly how you would go back and
correct an error that had come from the
fact that your measurements were biased
towards
um towards Urban and therefore of course
ended up showing you warming yeah and
we all should want to have our
scientists behaving this way and we all
should want to know we all should want
to know what is actually true
we all should okay so so that's um
that's one of the big pieces of this
paper is about the urban urbanization
bias uh in uh in the in the
data sets and therefore the models that
use those data sets that include uh
temperature station data from both urban
and rural areas since 1850. the other
one is
um
well here so this is uh from again the
beginning of the paper uh the authors of
the main authors of this paper from a
paper in 2021 anticipated two major
problems with the ipcc's
um uh uh what does AR stand for sorry
I've forgotten
um
I have to go back there it's it's
basically the intergovernmental panel on
climate change
um and assessment report assessment
report okay good
um so they had done assessment report
five and they were about to do
assessment report six and these guys
wrote a paper in 2021 that came just
late enough for the ipcc to not include
their recommendations in um in their
next report in AR6
uh they anticipated two major problems
Connolly at all did
um if AR6 repeated ar5's approach which
of course it did those two major
problems that they predicted were one
this is what we just talked about urban
areas represent a small fraction of the
global land area yet the land component
of the ipcc's global temperature
estimates include many urbanized weather
stations as a result there is concern
that they might be contaminated by
urbanization by us I.E worming biases
from the growth of urban heat islands
around weather stations so we've already
gone through that one that's just a
recap too
maths at all I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that correctly the total
solar irradiance TSI data set
recommended by the cmip6 organizers for
estimating past solar activity is a low
solar variability estimate
just like the four data sets considered
by these other modeling groups for error
five and implies a much smaller role for
the Sun than using a high solar
variability data set
let's explain for a moment before we
read a little bit more on this paper
um what are the potential contributors
to
um to climate and specifically to global
warming there are many but broadly
speaking we have anthropogenic we have
human we have sun and we have volcanoes
okay we have volcanism solar and
anthropogenic and they do talk about
some of the contributors of volcanism in
this paper but largely we're going to
talk here about human versus sun because
those are the two biggest ones that are
being talked about so you said human
volcanic and sun and sun and so
I know you're not excluding it because I
know it's definitely on your mind so it
must be buried in one of those but it
seems to me that there's a fourth
category and I think there are many
categories but what do you what like I'm
on Twitter hooks here what
um the
orbital Dynamics okay sure of the year
so the point here is not that there's a
lot of other things we're not talking
about volcanism either
um but um yeah so the malankovic Cycles
uh
you know maybe even that's included in
solar they must be including it as sun
right so
um so it's not what the the problem is
that sun has two things then the sun is
what's the sun putting out and then the
sun is also what are we receiving which
is yeah heavily contingent or just just
so volcanism is the simplest of those
three right like what what are the ways
that humans could be affecting climate
wow it's not just one thing it's not
just three things it's not just eight
things right similarly
um you know maybe rather than Sun it
should be called astronomical uh
influences uh and I don't I don't know
what all is included you know these are
these are these you know data sets and
models that are so multivariate that um
that you know basically not a client's
climate scientist I don't know what all
is included
um
but
if you assume if if you say okay let's
put aside
um let's just imagine for the moment in
a simple Universe which is not the one
that we live in the only possible
effects on climate are uh humans and sun
if you say well the sun doesn't change
that much therefore
and that would be a low solar
variability model the sun doesn't change
very much in terms of how it affects the
Earth
you will inherently then increase the
relative impact of humans on any change
that you see if you've only got those
two things and you say low solar
variability sun doesn't yeah the sun has
an impact for sure but it's pretty much
consistent over time you have guaranteed
the outcome that the role of
anthropogenic activities has a higher a
higher influence I can say that another
way yeah if you were allocating total
change to a are an artificially smaller
number of causes you will end up taking
causes you didn't account for and
putting it into those other modes where
it doesn't belong if the sun varies and
you assume it doesn't then you are going
to end up including the variability that
comes from the sun under some other
causal mode that it is not attributable
to exactly so these authors have used
what they're calling a high solar
variability data set they're not the
only only ones to do it they didn't
invent it there these these data sets
exist out there and they're available to
everyone but they started not with the
assumption that the sun varies a lot but
with the assumption that if we changed
our assumptions going in about the
degree to which the sun does vary
then we will then we will end up
attributing less of the change that we
have seen to human activity and that's a
pretty basic assumption and it's borne
out basically so I will say I now know
why uh orbital Dynamics don't show up
and I don't think they're buried in what
the sun is putting out in their model
it's because on the this time scale
they're irrelevant
yeah that's right the change is too slow
yeah
okay so
um a little more from this actual paper
so again we've got um the ipcc which
comes out I don't know what the
periodicity of their annual reports or
their attribution what are they what was
the ace floor assessment reports thank
you uh I don't think so um they can't
because they're only on six
um so the ipcc uh between putting out
its a its assessment report number five
and assessment report number six this uh
Connolly 20 Connolly at all 2021 paper
uh was published and they said here's
some things you need to be concerned
about urbanization bias and your low
variability solar your low solar
variability models uh data sets and uh
the ipcc said ah you came too late and
you know maybe they did apparently ten
and a half weeks too late we can't
include that in our in how it is that
we're going to go about doing this
uh doing this but
since then since the air six since the
assessment report number six from the
ipcc has come out uh there are a number
as as they say here a number of recent
Global temperature attribution Studies
have explicitly considered different
aspects of um that were mentioned in
this 2021 paper in their analysis
six uh are mentioned here three of these
studies agreed with Connolly at all 2021
that a much of the long-term warming
since the late 19th century could be
explained in terms of changing solar
activity
and B the ipcc had substantially
underestimated the solar contribution
two of the studies disagreed with
Connolly adult 2021 and concluded that
the solar contribution was very small
the remaining study reached an
intermediate conclusion finding that TSI
um that's the the models that are being
used uh or the solar excuse me um
finding that TSI was the dominant
climate driver up to 1960
but that afterwards CO2 appeared to
dominate
that looks like science to me right
we've got six published pieces of
research since Colony at all 2021
published and said here are two major
ways that the existing models are not
being rigorous about figuring out about
teasing apart the various effects that
might exist Six studies three of which
say yeah you may be right there not
certain but you may be right two of
which say yeah we don't think so we
still think that the sun plays a minor
role and one that is intermediate and
it's not actually intermediate it's
basically got an inflection point before
1960 they say sun and after 1960 they
say actually
um carbon is is there is there finding
uh that is what science especially in a
complex system will tend to look like we
haven't figured this out yet and when
you tweak parameters in your model you
can get wildly different results and
that tells you for sure
that the models are a big part of what
what is driving the frankly ideology of
climate change rather than the science
you know it's interesting the the
complex systems problem here intrudes in
multiple directions and whether it is
emphasized or de-emphasized is a
political question it shouldn't be but
what's happening here is you have a
series of layered complex systems the
stun does not appear to be a complex
system to those of us who look at it
from the Earth but it is one and the
likelihood that what it puts out is
constant is well it's just simply false
you can tell that it's simply false
because for example
you know coronal mass ejections uh
contain a lot of energy and they are
long off the sun there's a pattern in
terms of how frequently they're flung
off they are haphazardly flung off in
terms of Direction but the idea you know
if this was a perfectly uniform
Illuminator of the earth you wouldn't
have those kinds of effects and they're
clearly there so the Sunspot Cycle
coronal mass ejections put the lie to
low solar variability right the
variability is there and we can see it
on many different time scales we see a
sunspot cycle you know of sort of
decade-like cycle we see uh low periods
of activity you know within a year high
periods of activity these things all
suggest a highly Dynamic complex system
that we do not understand yeah it is not
a complex adaptive system right complex
adaptive system is different that's like
biology but it's a complex system like
hurricane well things on the Earth are
responding complexly and adaptively A2
warming that is happening absolutely the
technology and you know and and uh
ranges range distribution
um you know organisms moving north
towards the poles where they couldn't
survive before things like this right so
yes our reaction is there's a whole lot
of biology and therefore complex
adaptive systems interfacing it but the
sun doesn't know anything about them
it's just flinging out energy as it does
based on the fusion that's taken place
internally but if you think about
whether complex systems are going to be
emphasized when we're being panicked
about anthropogenic climate change then
of course the fact that we have this
massively complex system that we are
disrupting and therefore putting
ourselves in danger is the star of the
show right whereas the complex system
inside the Sun that means maybe we
actually can't be entirely certain about
what we think we're detecting because
even if we detect a warming down here on
Earth the question is is that uh an
anomaly of the data because it was
collected in heat islands is that an
anomaly of the Sun that we don't yet
understand uh you know in terms of how
much energy it was putting out what can
we infer from from uh you know past
solar environments based on indirect
evidence in ice cores or whatever
um so I guess the
what you would like scientifically
speaking is a consistent response to
complexity complexity ought to give you
pause about what you think you
understand and that both puts us in
danger with respect to disrupting
complex systems of life here on Earth
but it also puts us in danger
scientifically of getting stuff wrong
because we were still at the beginning
of understanding all of the inputs to it
right so our certainty should go down
because we're looking at complex systems
and that increases danger but it also
decreases Insight yes
all true
um
you know these people are cranks
maybe the people who did the research
have an ax to grind an ideological acts
to grind just like uh many have argued
those on the side of
um modifying all human behavior
immediately and permanently due to uh
you know rampant out of control it's
progenic climate change appear to have
an ideological acts to grind
let's see so this is series you can show
my screen here
the center for Environmental Research
and Earth Sciences is a
multi-disciplinary and independent
research group
lots more good things to say here are
three of the primary uh drivers at
series they're actually the three top
authors on uh the paper uh their mission
statement
in recent years the scientific Community
appears to have prioritized defining a
scientific consensus on any scientific
topic especially politically charged
topics we believe this obsession with
formia consensus contradicts the ethos
of true scientific inquiry and open it
in scientific research sounds like loons
to me
instead our approach to scientific
research is driven by a deep curiosity
to continually expand and revisit our
understanding of important scientific
I think they're not following the
science I think that's their problem so
just one more thing from their site
following is not their strong suit yeah
they're not followers that's their
problem that's probably why
um
well
support us it says how we are funded
just a little bit more about them in our
view scientific research works best when
it is independent what
from industry government religion
politics or ideology for this reason a
strict requirement for all our patrons
and funders is they do not attempt to
influence either the conclusions or
research directions of our group instead
we strive to ensure our research is
driven by objective evidence-based
analysis
like that um
rather different from
uh what many funders attempt and succeed
at doing with regard to driving
scientific both uh results but more
cryptically and maybe more importantly
the questions that are asked in the
first place so if certain kinds of
questions are never asked they don't
have to get into the into the mud and
actually change the the results that are
found because they can just keep the
questions from being asked in the first
place and that is part of why
independent research groups like this
one are so important
so
I'm gonna take a little license and step
out of this immediate topic for a moment
because something emerged um let's do it
I mean there's there's lots more to say
but can you show the uh the offit video
here what's an what's an offer that's I
mean
why don't you say more is a uh scientist
and vaccine evangelist who we have taken
to task for his presentation uh most
recently of the spike protein as the
reason for uh the Adverse Events that we
see coming out of the MRNA shots and I
accused him of knowing that that was
unlikely to be true and that in fact he
seemed to be trying to rescue the MRNA
platform from the Fatal flaw at its
heart this doesn't sound like a climate
question but what he said sounds like a
science question I believe Paul offit
beginning to feel the heat and that us
having leveled at him the accusation
that surely he knows better is now
creating in him an incentive to
um he's now rationalizing in public what
he's been doing and his rationalization
is fascinating so let's show the clip
our training as scientists is the
opposite of the training for being a
science Communicator I mean to be a good
scientist you never go beyond the data
in front of you never that's the worst
mistake you could make you feel you have
to reduce uncertainty by having caveat
after caveat after caveat that does not
work well on television or the radio I
mean you have to we get you can't really
say MMR vaccine doesn't cause autism you
can only say that with all the studies
that have been done it's extremely
unlikely you can't prove never you can't
reject the null hypothesis and you
always know that in the back of your
head you know you can't say that but you
say it anyway because it's true
MMR doesn't cause autism
it's just that the study I mean these
aren't mathematical Heroes who don't
have proofs
all right so what he says there is that
effectively when speaking to the public
you can't really be speaking in a
scientifically accurate way because what
scientists do is they never get ahead of
the data he's wrong about that he is
saying something that sounds right you
don't want scientists getting ahead of
the data but there is absolutely an
important scientific way in which we
scientists discuss what might be true
without misleading anybody about what we
know right and in fact this is true both
inside of science when we talk to other
scientists who are expert in the same
field
as it is true when we talk to the public
it sounds different but inside of
science there's an entire language for
uh referring for example to evidence
that you know exists that has not yet
been published right you say personal
communication you say I was speaking to
this person and they conveyed that in
their lab they've seen this thing well
it says I mean it's just it's inference
an inference is a huge part of what we
do as scientists and as humans but
specifically inference and you know he
is speaking as a like a platonic ideal
of an empiricist which does not exist
and also requires that inference
happened in order to collect whatever
data it is that he's now talking about
but the other side of what he said which
reveals how wrong he is also is
this sounds like what we used to hear
behind closed doors among our faculty
colleagues
the belief actually and anyone who's
ever been a student has
sometimes intuited that this is actually
what their teachers think of them
so many faculty actually think their
students are dumb and can't think and
just need to be you know just are
looking for grades and you know a job
afterwards and you know and don't don't
care and couldn't be bothered and
actually can't can't do
and
this attitude this this arrogance this
hubris is found
um for sure among scientists as well as
as other faculty and it's not just about
students it's about the entire public
the public can't do the math they can't
think through it they don't know what
science is they just have to be told a
result they just want to be told what it
is and what to do and be allowed to move
on with their day and it's not it's not
untrue
that all of us are overwhelmed by the
complexity of the world right that we
have way too many choices that we have
to make all the time and in some places
we'd like to be like who can I just
trust on this okay you can I just do
what you said to do and set and forget
and be done and that's of course how a
lot of people ended up where they were
on covid right but it's
reprehensible
and it is
successfully dumbing down people
when they aren't actually that dumb yeah
all of us are curious all of us have the
capacity pretty much most the vast
majority of us have the capacity to
assess nuance
and it is it is that you know the
science science communicators
are the ones who are just supposed to be
telling you an answer no they're not
that's what we've been led to believe
that's what we get you know I am science
says about you follow the science no
you can see exactly how this results in
a disaster uh of the sort that we have
um around all things covid and of the
sort that we have around anthropogenic
climate change because if you follow off
its argument to its logical conclusion
then when something important is at
stake we have something called science
communicators and these science
communicators are people who are trained
to do science and know that they cannot
do it in front of the public and what
they must do is present an artificially
clean picture of complex systems now
even if
a bunch of dumb actually believed
that once they established that system
where you get to lie to the public
because at the end of the day we need
the public to reduce its carbon
footprint what happens is somebody
figures out how you capture that voice
of the things that decent people are not
allowed to contradict in public and it
commandeers it for its own purposes that
have nothing to do with the public and
then imagine the following thing imagine
that people like you and I decide that
we want to talk about the science just
as we would have in a classroom where we
let people see the full messiness of the
process the full noisiness of the data
sets and all of the influences that we
don't yet understand then what happens
is they have to control the literature
because it's not there is no firewall
between the public hearing their science
communicators tell them an artificially
clean story and then what the scientists
say to each other because people are
listening into what the scientists say
so now you can't speak the truth at a
conference you can't speak to the truth
inside your department the point is
there just becomes this Orthodoxy that
is is an Article of Faith purely and it
just self-reinforces and casts out
anybody who looks at it and says
actually you've missed something
and
you know we were we were Rogue as
professors as well right
um
science is taught with textbooks right
because there's just too much of it to
do it any other way you can't have
people wallowing and all the uncertainty
and all of the wrong turns we've made
and the things that we've thought that
we now know weren't true no the way you
do it is you have the students buy a 300
textbook that has the truth the whole
truth nothing but the truth in it
because now on September 13th something
like that September 13th 2023 we have
finally arrived a complete and unfailing
human knowledge we were wrong until
right now and we will never be more
right than we are right now
this is the logic and I mean what
amazing hubris right and you will see
you will hear these like practical
sounding explanations oh it's too much
you don't have time you can't teach them
like that well so we're trained we're
not just assuming that the public is
filled with idiots who don't want to
think for themselves but so too are
students who are in college literally to
become scientists so of course most of
the scientists also don't know how to
think because they have been fed these
textbook versions of science since they
were students which apparent you know
back in you know whenever they were
students it was 1957 we know everything
and nothing shall change but everything
until right now was wrong or a lot was
wrong and you know in 1987 and in 2017
like all of these moments when any
student or member of the public
arrives to think about well I wonder
what's true ah you're lucky you arrived
today because until today we had so much
wrong but now we got this we nailed it
we have it
now what
what did he yeah well not only insanity
but it is setting us up for a disaster
let's say that the consensus on a global
climate change anthropogenic climate
change was about right
there would be nothing more reassuring
than watching people who were allowed to
question it find themselves having to
return to that conclusion because that's
actually where their skepticism brought
them it's true and that's why it stands
up to scrutiny whereas the idea that ah
as you depart from the Orthodoxy you're
committing some sort of moral offense
well of course there's every possibility
that we are missing important things and
the the license to lie that comes from
you cannot I mean just notice these two
things juxtaposed
he talks about the problem off it he
talks about the problem of being on uh
on CNN or MSNBC there's just you can't
you know he specifically uses the
example of autism and vaccines he says
um you know science does not allow you
to say with perfect certainty that they
don't cause it but we say it anyway
because in his basic point is because we
want people to get that message and
therefore we can't be honest with them
about the the ambiguity but it it
creates a you know so okay CNN and MSNBC
are the excuse and I will agree I've not
been on either of those things but I've
been on Fox that three-minute spot is
very difficult because there's not a lot
of room to get Nuance in there but what
do they do where there is room to get
Nuance in these same people don't say
well I said it overly precisely uh on
CNN because there wasn't a lot of time
but then I got on a three-hour podcast
and I did it properly the scientific way
that's not what he says right they go
after those of us who have tried to
explore these things on podcasts at
length with full Nuance they and they
treat that as some sort of an offense
too so yeah no and I would actually say
it's not you don't get Precision with
your three minutes you get
broad generalizations that actually lack
precision and often therefore move into
inaccuracy well yeah I mean of course I
would say what you get is precision over
something that is inaccurate yes um now
you get you get you get details that are
wrong yeah you get Precision not
accurate yes you get precision and not
accuracy
um and you know there is an art he's
first of all he is sliding into his
rationalization
um this data driven view of the world
the fact is it's entirely empirical like
I said right it is entirely empirical
which means you're not even doing
science dude science is hypothetical
deductive which means hypothesis is
ahead of the data right right like
literally that's what it is it's the
scientist speculating about what might
be true and then pursuing data to see
whether it is but we already know so
let's just do some science to
demonstrate that what we already know is
true right and let's do it that way the
paternalism of this he's insane right
this the science Communicator is going
to take what he or she ostensibly learns
from the actual science taking place
somewhere where people are allowed to do
Nuance they're going to artificially
purify it for your own good so that you
know that at the end of the day you
should get their vaccine or you should
reduce your carbon footprint or whatever
it is but the problem is
those of us who have been back where the
scientists are discussing this know how
garbagey this process is I mean witness
the the thing that we explored some
weeks back with the Cheap Trick
used to create the impression of
efficacy it's pure statistical artifact
and not spotted by peer review so
um go ahead well no I mean this is our
this is uh
this is another Zig back to um
climate stuff ish
often when climate comes up
uh no often when the environment comes
up
people assume that you're talking about
climate yep
and we have made a point for
long long before actually we were we had
any sort of public stage at all
of separating out these these two things
climate science inherently model based
inherently injected with the assumptions
of the people doing the work
um obviously informed by something that
is not entirely scientific because how
else could there be such broad consensus
when you're talking about models that
couldn't possibly have this level of
consensus if you were actually free to
choose the assumptions that you would
like to choose to wit we see those six
papers that we talked about where three
said yeah actually maybe there's some
more solar contribution two of which
said no we think it's mostly
anthropogenic one of which says actually
there's kind of an inflection point
around what was it 1960
um it's you know solar variability up
until then and then it starts to be
carbon dioxide like that's what
scientific results look like but when we
and I don't you know the the labels the
labels are getting really old but
um
if I were asked you know you're an
environmentalist yeah you know what and
I have been asked like what what thing
do you care about more than anything
else in in the world and it is the
environment we are doing
extraordinarily
uh I mean we are making extraordinarily
permanent changes uh to things that
people who haven't spent time in Wild
nature and especially people who haven't
spent time in Wild nature
um who are either studying it or who are
de facto studying it because they
because they have to understand it in
order to do what they're trying to do
there which might be something like
hunting or fishing honestly
um
might conflate environment with climate
but it is simply true that we are
destroying ecosystems that we can't get
back
that we are toxifying our land and our
water uh such that the insects are dying
and once the insects are dying the
songbirds are dying because they don't
have anything to eat and once the
songbirds are dying the predators that
eat the songbirds are dying which is the
wild dogs and the wild cats and the
Raptors and we've got you know not just
deforestation but D everything all of
these ecosystems are being destroyed for
our hunger for development
and that is all of those things are true
quite aside from what may or may not be
true about the human role in climate
change well I I know it's exactly what
you're saying but the very fact that we
are being lied to even if we
anthropogenic climate change is
approximately correct our model that we
are being present even if that's true
the fact that we are constantly being
lied to it to about it right is causing
people to tune out the entire set of
questions because climate change is
synonymous to most people with
environmental concern and so for those
of us who are skeptical of all of this
climate modeling because it can't it its
models right we know how bad those
models how How likely they are to
reinforce the pre-existing biases of the
people who are doing the modeling and we
know how toxic these environments are so
it is certain that those biases are
artificially creating a consensus that
then will be borne out by models that
mean nothing that's simply true and then
we are told that the models are dead
certain and that we're in an absolute
emergency and we need to turn the
economy of planet Earth upside down and
we need to you know constrain you to a
15-minute City and maybe you're gonna
have to eat bugs and all that stuff
right when people are being lied to that
way they become unreachable about the
stuff that we are clearly doing that we
can undo that is going to hurt your
children and your grandchildren they are
going to have a lesser Earth because the
climate Fanatics are making people deaf
to things that they would otherwise care
deeply about and it it's tragic it it's
it is yeah and it's unnecessary and you
know
well you don't get to lie you don't get
to lie about the science right this oh
no but they do all the time all the time
but the excuse right that we have to
present you know it is exactly what
you're describing we have to present an
artificially uh certain picture to the
public in order for them to give it in
which is not true you know people can
absolutely hear things like
um the cost benefit analysis surrounding
this treatment is worthwhile for you but
then they get to ask questions like okay
if it's worthwhile for a 75 year old
person with comorbidities is it also
worthwhile for a six-year-old who does
not is not threatened by the disease in
question and so that's why that's really
why they want to make this pure is
because no questions for you if you're
human you need this you need this right
and that is so obviously gameable and
captured by perverse economic interests
that become indifferent to those they're
killing because it is profitable to be
indifferent
um and that and that's where we are so
you know maybe you know maybe CNN and
MSNBC just simply need to come to an end
because their model of discussion is
harmful to people and maybe the point is
as with the discovery that the public
was ready to deal with much more complex
narratives than their you know three
camera sitcoms we're providing but it
needed a different business model you
know the long-form podcasting or
whatever comes after long-form
podcasting that lets things be explored
with their full messiness maybe that's
the way to interface with the public
um you know but either way you don't get
to lie about this stuff it's too
important
yeah it is
um
you wanted to talk about that ad
campaign from Apple yeah
um so I wanna which is it
decently related it is quite related so
uh there's this like five minute video
that just came out from Apple in the
last couple of days last couple of days
uh in which
um starring black woman is Mother Nature
yeah it's a skit that they have uh put
on super high production values of
course and it is causing a tremendous
amount of eye roll oh conservatives just
hate it right yeah yeah and I must say
personally uh
I was I don't know what to think of it
are we going to show a tiny bit yeah
let's show it let's show a little bit
it's really worth watching the whole
thing but um electricity electricity
status uh uh we're operating on a 100
clean electricity what runs on 100 clean
electricity every Apple office store and
data center runs on clean electricity
thanks to you and your powerful wind and
sun and apple offices are already carbon
neutral yeah this building is carbon
neutral yeah we do it with a mix of
clean energy and eliminating Greenhouse
emissions it's kind of like if you or
two you're seriously explaining carbon
neutrality to Mother Nature right no I'm
sorry you want to tell me how
photosynthesis works too don't
um also over 300 suppliers have
committed to using 100 clean renewable
electricity
so
um
I found this to be and I don't I don't
know about that particular clip but the
whole thing a very mixed bag actually
it's just it's it's mixed well let's put
it this way I am troubled by the fact
that the reaction to it is
uh
cynical which I think is probably
Justified at one level but the problem
is I don't even think we get to check
anymore because right this is to your
Corners yeah to your corners and the
problem is
a because this is about anthropogenic
climate change and apple uh using this
narrative to uh toot its own horn about
its accomplishments
um the point is everybody who is
skeptical of the story about
anthropogenic climate change and the
fact that we need to turn the economies
of you know all the nations of the world
upside down in order to address this
problem has the same reaction to it and
I share some of that reaction right on
the other hand carbon offset credits
right I don't know whether apple is uh
completely hypocritical here or they're
actually reporting on some positive
stuff what I know is that I'm incapable
I don't sit in a position where I can
evaluate how well apple is doing on this
front because what this is is PR but I
do know you know let's take a a an
adjacent example
there's a question about Tesla and how
sustainable its model for cars is based
on the fact that cars uh that electric
cars have batteries that require
elements that cause you know Warfare in
remote parts of the world and uh you
know unsustainable living conditions
exploitation of child labor for the
mining of materials and things and
Tesla's actually done a pretty good job
of changing their battery chemistry
around a long-term more sustainable
model of mining
so with regard to this video though
um
you know carbon offset credits is uh is
imminently gamable you know made
ridiculous it's it's it's ridiculous but
they say in this protecting soil plants
and trees well okay
trees are plants but that's what they
say protecting soil plants and trees and
there's this little back and forth
between mother nature and one of the
Apple employees we've planted forests
where Paraguay Brazil are you trying to
save the tropical Savannah
she says yes like Savannah and Forest
aren't the same thing this this to me
this like jumped out at me it's like
this is the this is a super high
production value five minute video from
Apple in which they just forgot that
Savannah isn't the same as forests
like what is that that seems like a
stupid error to have made but they also
say okay we've stored mangroves in
Colombia we've registered grasslands in
Kenya like that has value to the extent
that things can be restored you can't
you can't go into a place that's been
denuded of all natural life for a
hundred years and so we planted some
stuff it's back we got Forest again like
you don't have Forest you might have a
few trees but that's not a forest yeah I
agree with you you you can't plant a
forest especially a tropical one we
don't understand nearly enough you can
ReStore Habitat and then hopefully you
get to a place where nature takes over
and you know I mean what we've seen in
the eastern U.S is that forests that
were denuded are now again Forest but
they're not the same for us but I mean
this I mean this is this is forestry
management language not ecology language
we've planted Forest nope right no you
did not planted something that looks
superficially like a forest maybe I
don't take the same exception I don't
read the same way the idea of of I don't
see the conflation between
um I mean she says we planted forests
where Peregrine Brazil so you're trying
to save tropical Savannah like what I
think it was are you trying to save
tropical surveillance so that could be a
new topic but anyway it's not I mean let
me go back and listen to it very clearly
yeah so I mean it just it's both tiny
and this is gonna like I'm gonna come
off as pedantics like you know what
Forest is not Forest like a piece of the
the Ecuador on Amazon is not the same as
a piece of um boreal forest in Alaska in
Alaska say it's just it's just not they
have completely different
characteristics but also value to the
earth and the and the organisms in it uh
and
um the fact is that there's lots of
places on the Earth where you could
plant trees but you shouldn't because
that's not what is going on there and so
we have these incredibly simple rubrics
I'm like oh we're gonna plant trees
plant trees is the things like some
places but a you can plant trees but you
can plant forests that's different
different levels of complexity and also
there are places where you wouldn't
plant trees and frankly if you're
planting trees in the savannah what are
you doing and you know so so how much do
they know about what they're actually
doing and there's another thing in here
of um
they take on this guy for wearing a
leather jacket they're trying to reduce
leather to nothing
so so there's like confusion mixed in
with actually
restoring mangroves in Colombia that
does seem like a doable thing like we've
been places where mangroves are being
restored and uh and it protects the land
behind them as well it effectively acts
as a Breakwater and it
um and it collects nutrients and then
you get more land growing and you get
more protection it's protection for the
fish that live inside for the fish while
they're maturing it's you know it's it's
extraordinary and it's not particularly
useful for humans but mangroves are uh
you know a remarkably diverse and you
know highly highly variable between
um between places
um set of ecosystems that if you know if
part of what is happening here is a move
to actually think carefully about where
there are places that we could reverse
some of the move to to Denude the land
good we need that we need that so uh
the leather thing is particularly odd
because there's a whole level of
analysis that's implied there that I
doubt was done which is you know leather
is a product of animals obviously
animals can be quite destructive
depending upon where you're raising them
on the other hand if you're raising them
for meat wasting the leather doesn't
make any sense in fact it's probably
environmentally good that you're not
using some other material which means
that if this is thought through they're
trying to reduce the number of animals
raised from meat to zero or they're not
or they're just posturing and and so
anyway the reason I wanted to raise this
is because on the one hand you can hear
our cynicism our cynicism is through the
roof because we're sick of being lied to
and it is causing us to have a reaction
to the idea and this is we actually know
about this stuff right like we actually
know about these sorts of ecosystems
that they clearly don't right well
you know when you watch a car commercial
and the car goes
um
whizzing around the Curves in the
highway in a way that would probably or
you know slide up no across the uh the
lake bed in a way that would violate
your warranty if you bought the car and
did it oh oh it's like not that it
breaks physical principles the PR
department is not in contact with the
engineers and the warranty department
right they're separate Endeavors yeah so
I don't know what the hell is going on
at Apple I do think apple is in an
interesting position because it is not
what we would call an efficient market
there's so much power involved in the
brand of Apple in part because people
deal with it as a as a religion
um and in part because Apple has done
such a good job of making a refined
product that it isn't it's not easy to
get up to get fed up with apple and just
buy somebody else's version because
you're you know okay now you're in the
Android world and you've got that set of
problems so the point is this is a
company practically advertising for them
right here but let's let's think about
the
um in an efficient market where you have
lots of competitors producing something
similar and then some competitor decides
you know what we'd like to produce it
sustainably well what just happened oh
you just went out of business because by
producing it sustainably you drove up
the price you didn't deliver anything
extra to your customers so those people
who ignore the fact that you're
producing it sustainably
um and you know buy something else do
damage but they personally come out
ahead so it's all very well and good for
Apple to do this because they've got as
close to a legal Monopoly as it's
possible yes but
first of all all of us who are paying
attention uh to the uh ESG rubric no it
is a disaster because it is so heavily
politicized and it is being used as a
bludgeon to
um Elevate companies that partner with
certain political ideologies Etc that
should not be going on
that does not mean that we should as a
species be shaming
companies that try to figure out how to
do things in ways that either pollute
less yes that uh get more for the same
amount of materials are are more
efficient those are things that we
should find laudable and to the extent
that they are also good business and
this is a point that Bobby Kennedy makes
beautifully
um that you know pollution is economic
inefficiency you're losing something
into the environment
um and so anyway we are now the public
is now at Cross purposes with itself
because we are so used to being lied to
and we are so cynical because we are
being lied to that we react to the very
idea of doing business in a less
destructive way as inherently uh false
and probably harmful and probably
political and they're probably stealing
from us as they're doing this in some
way that we can't even see and that is a
mistake the savings will be passed on to
us right so we
I literally don't know how to think
about this ad I find the I find the the
ad a bit cringy but I also know that you
know
um but maybe they're earnest
I don't know right but that's like I go
back and forth to it's like oh it's
cringy and like are you are you just
being hypocritical
or some of you Earnest and you really
are trying to do good and and some of
what they described doing seems like it
would do good and some of it is just
silly or Worse right but what you don't
want to do is get into a situation where
somebody who does the right thing gets a
wave of cynicism that punishes them for
trying to do the right thing and I'm not
saying that this is or isn't Apple
trying to do the right thing I'm not
saying frankly
that what they're portraying as their
actual environmental posture is an
accurate representation of anything I
find it unlikely and especially in light
of the fact of Apple's history of doing
things like
um creating bony demand for its phones
by programming them to fail
um artificially quickly you know in
other words the battery failure was
partially induced in order to get people
to buy more phones and so that that's
fun right
um but actually I wanted to I wanted to
raise a parallel example that I think is
very interesting uh that people will
probably not have thought of
um some years ago Volkswagen got into
tremendous trouble for gaming uh the
emission standards they effectively
programmed vehicles to trick this these
the test apparatus so that they appeared
to be less polluting than they were and
it's like 10-ish years ago yeah we're
not talking about World War II era no it
was a big it was a big deal
now I had a interaction we uh we got a
Toyota truck that replaced the Toyota
truck that we had had for many many
years
um and a totally different phenomenon uh
surrounds it so all the car
manufacturers are subject to the same uh
Cafe standards that are ostensibly
supposed to decrease emissions
Etc
but what I discovered about this truck
was that it had been artificially
hobbled by its manufacturer so that it
was not responsive to you putting your
foot on the gas pedal uh it has a lag
built into that responsiveness now the
reason that this is interesting is that
the way this is done
is so easy to defeat that of course
there is a simple product that anybody
who gives a damn about this can purchase
that simply removes this lag right it is
as if the manufacturer wanted
it to be discovered by the aftermarket
that there was a way for Toyota to pass
its tests without cheating so with the
lag there's better gas mileage yes this
is that's oversimplified from an
engineering perspective doesn't matter
averaging of data not a lag the fact is
these two things amount to the same
effect
right you have in one case a
manufacturer doing something criminal
gaming a standard so that their vehicles
are not as efficient as they appear to
be
um
and in the other case you have a
manufacturer within the law allowing the
aftermarket to solve a problem that
causes the same net impact
now
it's a very you know so static rules get
gamed static rules get gamed and then
there's a question about well what
should we really want how important is
it the CO2 that is being put out of
these vehicles how important is it and
of course we can't even I would like to
know right we it is important that we
know and
um there were a lot of us who were
actually very interested well let's put
it this way though there's no way
the
imagine Two Worlds
one world we discover that human
um human released CO2
is not a major factor in uh in climate
that other factors dominate yep well
that is a world in which a lot of
activity is economic activity is
Unleashed because its impact is not
important
the other world is the world we live in
where we're told with regard to the
particular metric that we were talking
about well that's the interesting thing
about CO2 is that it is it only matters
if it is trapping heat from the Sun at a
rate that affects the climate here on
Earth
it's not toxic right but all that other
economic activity is going to have other
effects and we're not looking at those
other effects because that's not what
we're focused on right now and again you
know my noise is your hypothesis right
but
trade-offs being trade-offs
what you want to do is prioritize the
things that have the biggest negative
impact and you want to put your effort
your control efforts on those things and
just as with the case of the leather
jacket right either
it is actually a a ecologically positive
thing to use leather because the meat is
being used anyway and throwing away the
leather and then making a vinyl
you know replacement for it is extra
activity that doesn't need to have
pollutants put into the world I will say
that's this is one of my always
questions is awesome yes let's get rid
of plastics what are we replacing it
with right what like I mean we also
can't do leather can we not do trees
either or is it all glass where's the
glass coming from like what what are we
allowed to use steel and glass right is
that where we're left what you want is a
dispassionate net analysis about how
much harm actually comes from this thing
and you know here let's take another
example double pane windows okay double
pane windows that definitely increase
the efficiency of your home by allowing
you to maintain a temperature without
losing so much heat or losing so much
cool to the outside environment problem
is
these sealed units go bad and never do
you see a calculation in which the
energy to produce a replacement sealed
unit and to deal with the now useless uh
trash never do we see that dangerous
because it's sharp right like it's not
it
the point is hey
this I agree a sealed window unit has a
benefit we can all see it it has a cost
we don't talk about and until we talk
about both things we don't know what is
it Ro value is that is that the number
something just r value
um yeah you own you see you see the
analysis with regard to only the R value
and not with regard to the you know the
entire industry and like okay on this
window
if I put a double plane double pane
window in and I expect to to want to
look out that window and have my home
heated on the inside and not on the
outside for 40 years
what can I expect how many times will I
have to replace one or both pans because
often you can't just do one yeah you
have to buy it as a unit so how many
times am I going to have to not just
take this out and send it to the
landfill but pay for the labor and pay
in and the cost of making the new one
and you know all of this as opposed to
you have a pane of glass you know other
than other than the you know kid in the
baseball under the window like you know
sure Windows break but uh it's just
gonna be there forever well and no doubt
there is a sweet spot right you can have
those two panes and you can get
60 of the insulation value that you
would get from a sealed pain without
them being sealed which means that you
don't have the problem of the seal
blowing and then causing your window to
get cloudy if they're not sealed though
you're going to get condensation and
such well but the question is how many
of these things could be mediated in a
way that you can correct it yeah I don't
I don't I don't think that's a solution
here because precise you know you know
that it was it was people used to do
storm windows and storm windows well
it's storm windows though I mean in fact
the house we lived in in Michigan had
storm windows right and uh you know we
put them on uh take off the screens and
put on the star on Windows in in the
winter and um you know single pane class
in in Ann Arbor Michigan was not an
effective way to heat a house that was
built in what was it like 1947 that
little that little house we lived in
um but every year you know we clean the
glass on both sides and you know it's
we're talking about six months and then
it comes off again and but I'm not
arguing I'm not arguing for that okay
storm windows suck but
technologically speaking you don't have
to make you know think about it this way
if you've got a sealed unit and it goes
bad you're throwing away
two panes of glass and you are you know
I don't know how much energy goes into
creating it's not air in between those
two panes of glass of glass so you know
there's a there's an industrial process
that goes to creating the impressively
high r value yeah and all I'm saying is
what is actually if you if you were
actually concerned about energy usage
there's some net analysis here and then
there's some question about well how
much would you you know relax your
desire for more energetic efficiency to
reduce a bit of pollution that matters a
great deal we don't do these analyzes
because we're playing some and hassle
for the homeowner uh that then could
allow them to be more productive
economically or otherwise productive in
the world that then Returns value that
is not being measured in your current
equation right and we are we are not
doing any of these net analyzes because
all of these things have become symbolic
right that we feel like our homes are
vastly more efficient because of the
standards that we are applying but
really the you you want the net standard
and what we've got are these overly
focused standards that do maybe maximize
one thing but if you don't know what the
cost in energy of the system of Windows
you have chosen is then you don't really
know anything and
has anyone in our history of living in
various places in various structures and
had to replace a lot of windows
ever been able to begin to answer the
question of actual net
no I remember a few conversations that
you you broached uh with people who were
you know good people smart people who
were like I wouldn't even I all I can
tell you is the r value right like I
just I wouldn't even begin to know how
to do the analysis and there's no
percentage in it because the fact is
it's actually you know so many
Industries have done this where they've
got something that masquerades as a
solution to one problem but it's really
the solution to the problem of an
economically depressed sector so in
bicycles for example
a well-built steel bicycle does anything
that an aluminum or Titanium or carbon
bicycle can do it's slightly heavier it
not enough to matter it's well done
and it'll last you your whole life so
bike industry has a problem which is
that a lot of people buy one buying an
accident you can fix it yeah right
um on the other hand if we can sell you
a fancy plastic bicycle and call it
carbon fiber so you don't realize it's
plastic and then you have to replace it
periodically because we've now sold you
a bicycle right a plastic bike it's yeah
it's chemically an organic
thing which is not a long rather low
tensile strength
um
right I mean that's that's the issue
with carbon fiber or at least let's put
it this way under the right conditions
the expected conditions it's a great
material
um and you know I think for camera
tripods it's the right material
um for a bicycle when your safety is
depending on the thing not suddenly
breaking on you while you're riding at
high speed it's a terrible material
um but the forces come at you in rather
unexpected ways when you're bicycling
well you can let's put it this way as
long as everything is as the
manufacturer anticipated no problem but
that doesn't mean that somebody uh
didn't hit your bike with some you know
shopping cart while you were in a store
and you didn't know it and so it
developed a small crack it's got a
stress fracture right exactly so anyway
point being
um carbon fiber bicycle solved a serious
problem but it was a problem an economic
problem for bicycle manufacturers it was
not a problem for the consumer and this
idea that you know hey selling people
replacement uh sealed window units is
good business if you're selling Windows
because it causes people to replace
windows that otherwise wouldn't have
needed it so you may not be all that
interested in figuring out whether or
not the energy lost in making new window
units is uh more than the energy saved
by the unity when you buy new windows
right so people they don't think about
it it's not a common question right
um
all right I had one more thing did you
have more
I mean I want to talk about libraries
all right
um so let's do one more thing on climate
and then we can move to libraries
I wanted to argue
that we should actually address
climate change whether or not it's
anthropogenic
and that there is one although I am
absolutely dead set against
geoengineering because I think it is
just the most insane example of people
overestimating what they understand
about a complex system and it invites so
many disasters you know for example you
want to blow up the moon now I'm not
willing to blow up the moon
um I like the moon for lots of reasons
some of them aesthetic and I can't
defend it at all but I just think it's
cool okay we'll take that off the list
for now all right the moon stays okay um
but you know let's take a an obvious
example or two you know geoengineering
could involve putting particles in the
atmosphere to block oh my God these
people right exactly right how could
that possibly go right
but we need is less sunlight on the
earth that's going to make everything
sunlight on the earth which will affect
let's see everything
um and you know affect human health
directly etc etc okay that's a dumb idea
I mean it like it's like dumb it's as
dumb as blowing up the moon dumb to the
10th power yeah right equally dumb hey
let's fertilize the oceans with uh you
know
limiting reagents such that they pick up
carbon by creating algae there's all
sorts of ideas
what that meant I don't know I didn't
track that well fertilizing the oceans
is it copper there's plans uh to adding
some So when you say fertilizing I don't
know what fertilizations use so you just
said copper adding some limiting element
to the oceans that some things uh that
live in the oceans are constrained by
because it is limiting for them that
once they have more of say it's copper
maybe it's molybdenum right then they
will start proliferating and by
proliferating they will make more carbon
because we live on earth and we have
carbon-based life is that they will
capture carbon that is otherwise they
will I don't I'm sorry I said make more
carbon they will they will use more
carbon and then what they will sequester
it and as long as there's there's like
short-lived what are they like
planktonics some things like what
happens that get an equilibrium
I mean look
it's not that they're first order wrong
that you could change things in some
direction that would have a net impact
what they're wrong about is
that you don't know all of the things
you're going to affect
um and so all your second third and
fourth order effects are going to be
devastating but any more bio
ocean biomass is the solution to the
okay I mean look
first of all you've got a religion based
on the idea yeah that it is this
um non-toxic
transparent molecule in the atmosphere
that is overwhelmingly going to mess up
our
uh
our climate and that's why you need to
sell your leather jacket
saw your leather jacket and eat bugs
um but okay so here's here's going to be
my argument for what we actually should
do
okay I'm dubious about anthropogenic
climate change and how serious it is I'm
not saying it's not serious as I've
mentioned many times before the Uranus
equation is not new and it does suggest
that changing the carbon concentration
of the atmosphere will trap more Heat
and the question is really not whether
that is happening but whether it's
happening enough to matter
um that's one thing second thing this is
not a minor issue if we are affecting it
enough to matter because there is a
parameter that we
as far as I know can be certain of
that makes this very high sticks which
is the trapped methane in the Arctic so
what you do not want to do is tread into
novel territory where
um the Arctic starts to unfreeze at a
new level because if that happens the
release of methane which is a much more
potent greenhouse gas will cause an
increase in warming which will cause a
decrease in Arctic Ice which causes a
darkening of the planet which captures
more of the Sun's light so you mentioned
Albedo before yeah
um I will try to do this efficiently but
the thing to know what we know quite
apart from global climate change any of
that discussion
from a Serbian uh
uh climatologist named malankovic this
was his Insight was that there are this
is from like early mid 20th century yeah
yeah there are three ways in which the
orbit of the earth is not perfectly
regular there are three cycles and these
cycles each of them has a tiny effect on
the amount of the sun's energy that
lands here and sticks right one of them
has to do with the degree of the Earth's
Tilt which changes slightly or at 23 and
a half now but we go between 22 and a
half and 24 and a half ish I think
there's a one we're right about in the
middle yeah right now there is a
procession of the North Pole that is to
say where the North Pole points in the
universe
this will be known to people as the
difference between the magnetic north
and the like Cardinal north of the
compass north
um
not
really it's a yeah it you would detect
it in whether the North Star was north
um
so the magnetic north is a feature of
idiosyncrasies in the composition of the
earth oh okay okay
um but okay so the procession where the
North Pole points the procession of the
actual North Pole Point okay yes if you
spin a top yes you will watch the stalk
of the top go like this that's
procession so there's a cycle yeah that
is the procession of the Earth's axis
rotational axis there is a degree of the
Tilt is it tilted more or less and then
there's an obliquity of the orbit how
circular versus oblong is the orbit and
these three things are unconnected to
each other and they have very different
Cycles I think one is a hundred thousand
years one is something like 41 000 years
and one is closer to twenty thousand
years yeah and so the problem is that
these things sometimes line up
so that it slightly reduces the amount
of the sun's energy that lands on the
earth and sticks and sometimes increases
it when they are in Phase versus out of
phase and this is what drives ice ages
but here's the key thing it's also going
to
where the land masses are on the earth
will affect to what degree the
procession and and the obliquity of the
of the of the orbit but especially to
what degree the tilt of the earth
um quickly affects temperatures on the
earth on land and in water right yeah
it's gonna because a greater tilt of the
Earth is going to make seasonality even
greater at the poles yep
so the key thing though is that all of
these Cycles even put together have a
very small impact on how much uh he
ends up in on the Earth
what they do though is they trigger an
amplifier
and the amplifier is what Heather
referred to earlier it's Albedo and
Albedo has to do with when energy from
the Sun hits the Earth it either bounces
back into space or it is absorbed and
heats the place
and the key thing is that when water is
Frozen
Arctic uh ice cap for example it's white
that's very reflective it bounces a lot
of energy back into space when there's
more ice it bounces energy back into
space When there's less ice and
therefore ice begets ice right the more
ice the cooler things get and so the
melanchovic Cycles independently aren't
enough to make a huge difference but
what they do is they change how much ice
persists over the northern Summer and
the more ice that persists over the
northern summer the more energy from the
Sun is bounced back into space just by
being reflected the cooler Things become
so it's a positive feedback in either
direction now the reason that this
matters is that if we are affecting the
climate and we reach a place where we
start releasing the Frozen methane in
the Arctic at a novel level and I'm not
saying that we are or not going to do
that but I'm saying I don't think
anybody knows enough to know for sure if
we do that then this becomes a process
that we can no longer control because
the dominant effect of large amounts of
methane being released from the Arctic
would take climate into a whole new
phase so our intuition is based on the
amount of warming that may or may not
have happened while we have been alive
is not a good model for what might
happen if we get there and so my point
is I don't know if we're headed there
but I don't want to find out right I
don't want us to get to a novel place
where we are suddenly releasing large
amounts of methane then the Arctic Ice
does recede not saying it's happening
but if it did that would be very very
bad
so what I'm going to suggest is that
there is one and only one type of
geoengineering that makes sense with
respect to dealing with that possibility
wow okay I have no idea what's coming
yeah I have no idea what's coming but
interestingly it fits perfectly with our
Hanukkah tradition which we discuss in
our book okay um our book which I
neglected to bring here here you can
hold on to the zebra
zebra represents our book He's mostly a
gatherer not so much a hunter but in any
case he doesn't gather he just he just
he doesn't save anything
right yeah
um
in our book we argue that human activity
should
uh in the long run be both sustainable
and reversible and the idea is that
sustainability isn't really enough
because
time and time again what we have
discovered is that we have Unleashed
processes technologically
that when they were small we didn't know
were a problem and at the point that
they become a problem we literally don't
have the ability to reverse course
that puts us in great danger so what I
would suggest is that the way
to create a Fail-Safe for climate has to
do with artificial Albedo
now this is going to have implications
that would have to be looked at
carefully I'm not the first person to
suggest this by the way
um so things like things that I have
seen are like making blacktop White
right which and and and and painting
roofs that that are dark white well
let's put it this way those especially
in cities especially to deal with the
urbanization effect right you could make
a strong argument for white roofs now
white roofs if you did it with paint
that paint is likely to be white by
virtue of uh titanium which is not cheap
so I'm not arguing that hey here's a
freebie you can whiten stuff up right
you're talking about processes that all
have implications paint is not an
environmentally free product so one does
have to look at the cost
and it may be that uh cities should have
white roofs
um because that would counteract in part
their tendency to concentrate heat it's
also possible that the whitening that
would be necessary to counteract warming
um
should be distributed in some useful way
to minimize the harm that it undoubtedly
will cause because it is an interference
in a system and so it will have impacts
on things and it could be you know the
fact is it will matter somewhat but what
you're looking at is a net reflectivity
and so by changing in that reflectivity
down here on Earth
you could modulate if we did find
ourselves headed towards some threshold
that threatened to release methane
clathrates at a novel level from the
Arctic that you could actually change
that but the important thing about this
versus all of the other proposals I've
heard of for geoengineering is that it's
reversible if it turns out that it was a
very bad idea you can undo it because
it's down here on Earth and it's not you
know uh an infinite number of particles
that you released and you can't get back
the point is if painting stuff white
wasn't a good idea you can change it
back to whatever you know
make it white on one side and flip it
over right
um flip over your roof
you're not your roof but yeah no you're
not saying it's simple but you're saying
it's doable I'm not saying it's simple
and I'm not saying that it is
environmentally well it's not neutral
it's not for sure without major costs it
will have major inherently neutral what
I would like to know is that it is worth
those costs we are you know let's face
it we are stewards of the Earth at this
point because our effect is so profound
on it that we will change it whether we
do that intentionally in ways that are
desirable or at least tolerable or
whether we do it in ways that are
haphazard and very destructive
but nonetheless so what I'm getting at
is you're hearing somebody who is
skeptical of those models
right I don't know that we are in a
climate emergency but the possibility
that we are in a climate emergency is
real I didn't get that from the modelers
that's a question of the Arrhenius
equation and the tendency of carbon
which we are increasing uh the amount of
in the atmosphere to trap heat they're
due as far as I know they're real
methane clathrates trapped in large
quantities in the Arctic so all of these
things are subject to Albedo we know
that from uh the lesson of malankovic
cycles and the amplifier that is in
Arctic ice so what that means is we
could build our own amplifier that is
subject to our
understanding of whether or not
something important is happening and we
could modulate climate and
the punch line of this is that then we
get to and I hope we would do it much
more responsibly than we're doing it but
then we get to keep living right we
don't have to be limited to 15-minute
cities we're not going to have to eat
bugs we can actually control the impact
of our own uh effect on climate if in
fact it is important that we do so
excellent that's my opinion let's do it
I don't think we can do it I think it's
going to require more people and frankly
a lot of paint
uh you should who who is which paint
company has the most awful slogan in the
entire world
Sherwin-Williams cover the Earth cover
the Earth well here you go this is this
is their moment I guess Unfortunately
they have really high quality paint but
who let them put that all over their
trucks and my God yes cover the and they
literally have like a paint can covering
here in there it's not an appealing idea
no and yet and yet here you are
proposing very much the same thing
I don't want to just pour it on here
yeah it doesn't have to be paint but
well the problem is you do need an awful
lot of whatever it is and the nice thing
about paint is that it is already
formulated to uh have minimal thickness
for maximum reflectance I mean that's
kind of what pain is right
um yeah yeah it's there's already a
product that does this job no but what
if you like designed blacktop with rocks
that were lighter like you don't have to
use you don't have to cover things with
a white substance to make things yeah no
I actually as an engineering uh question
like what could you make blacktop out of
that was these are all of the things
yeah but it was more reflective as
opposed to absorbent but the pro look
hey ultimately I think you're going to
end up with something that we will end
up calling pain and the reason is
because if you imagine how much White
Rock you have to uh mine in order to do
this with rock rather than paint it's
way worse because what the paint does is
it takes microscopic Rock and just lets
you see the face of all of it I mean the
the blacktop question also is those
roads are going to get dark from the
tires and the exhaust and the vehicles
very quickly so they're you know they're
not going to stay light for very long
and they're going to look terrible also
yeah and it may it may be bad for people
to drive looking at White roads that are
you know
blaring huge numbers of photos I I don't
know but I we should separate the
question there's some best way to use to
take control of Albedo without
destroying the planet over it such that
if this is the issue that some people
fear
we have a mechanism for modulating it
good
all right um
we've been at it for a while but I just
I want to say just a little bit about
what's going on in Canada in the uh whoa
yeah it's Canada again I mean we thought
we thought we have it stupid down here
in the United States
man Trudeau is losing leading the charge
continues to lead the charge up in
Canada actually I don't know that this
is true though I think this may be a
Canada government taking stupid to new
latitudes ah man yeah okay so here we go
this is the CBC the Canadian broadcast
Corporation
you can show my screen empty shells with
absolutely no books students parents
questions school boards library reading
process
books published in 2008 or earlier
removed from school library amid
confusion around new equity-based
process
whoa yeah Equity based here we go okay
so um it's a it's a good article I will
of course link it here but let's just go
down to um
books published prior to 2008 that are
damaged inaccurate or do not have strong
circulation data are not being checked
out by students are removed said the
board in its statement this is going to
seem like the the weakest objection
possible but the idea that because
students aren't checking out books we
should get rid of them is more of the
same insane like student-driven child
driven like trust the naive who don't
yet know what they're doing
to decide what it is that they should be
exposed to that's not what life
oh I have a whole other objection to I
agree that that's absurd I mean there's
a billion objections we're getting to
them no no but to that particular
provision okay
the idea
okay every time somebody checks a book
out of a library there's some impact
right it's tiny or it's Cosmic
the idea that the books that are having
the important impacts are the ones that
are being checked out by everybody
rather than the book that somebody finds
that has just the thing necessary to put
the two things together that nobody
realized went together that it unleashes
the uh no but esoteric is useless Sprint
rare is useless how can we how can we
get everyone in lockstep if we're not
all reading the same stuff it is a weird
I don't even know that they
they thought thought in these terms in
these terms but it is one of these like
consensus drivers only the books that
everybody's reading yeah
it's even worse than that here we go uh
Okay so
she'll evaluate books media and all
other
s currently in use for teaching and
learning English History and social
sciences for the purpose of utilizing
resources that are inclusive and
culturally responsive relevant and
reflective students and the board's
broader School communities reads the
directive
how weeding works and yes it says
weeding not reading how weeding works
pdsbs that's whatever the board here is
um Equitable curation cycle is described
generally in the board document as quote
a three-step process that holds peel
staff accountable for being critically
conscious of how systems operate so that
we can dismantle inequities and Foster
practices that are culturally responsive
and relevant
first teacher Librarians were instructed
to focus on reviewing books that were
published 15 or more years ago so in
2008 or earlier
then Librarians were to go through each
of these books and consider the widely
used musty acronym adapted from Canadian
School libraries the letters stand for
the criteria Librarians are supposed to
consider and they include misleading
information may be factually inaccurate
or obsolete unpleasant refers to the
physical condition of the book may
require replacement fine if it's got
mold get a new one in good superseded
book
Ben over okay there's a word missing
there or the Librarians don't know how
to write or something superseded book
been overtaken by a new addition or a
more current resource
but overtaken
whatever whatever we know what it means
yeah trivial of no discernible literary
or scientific Merit poorly written or
presented
irrelevant doesn't meet the needs and
interests of the library's community
and elsewhere the book of the material
in it may be better obtained from other
sources
yeah certainly after they remove it from
the library
the deadline to complete this step was
the end of June according to the
document step two of curation is an
anti-racist and inclusive audit where
quality is defined by quote resources
that promote anti-racism cultural
responsiveness and inclusivity end quote
and step three is a representation audit
of how books and other resources reflect
student diversity
so this article begins uh with a story
of a 10th grader at a school whose
library has been so affected who reports
that having left school at the end of
the spring uh she enjoyed her Library a
lot she says she spends all of her
lunches in her library and the shelves
were full and that now they're about 50
percent empty
fifty percent
and and it includes Harry Potter
apparently the hungry hungry caterp The
Very Hungry Caterpillar The Very Hungry
Caterpillar has been taken out of some
libraries because it's older than 2008.
well it's also transphobic
[Laughter]
yes and and how many caterpillars go to
school after all
right it does not reflect the broader
needs of the community of school-going
children unless there are some who
declare themselves caterpillars or
butterflies which some of them may do
so
help me out here I I have already in in
um listening to you describe the uh the
interstices of this horror yes
forgotten how empty shelves help
uh let's see they help let's see if we
can generate how they must help uh they
help because those who would be offended
by the things that were on full shelves
no longer at risk of being offended both
because again we have obtained full and
complete knowledge here in 2023 and
while certainly we weren't there in 2008
we can assume that in the last 15 years
we have been approaching this Pinnacle
of omniscience that we have now obtained
and before 15 years ago we were so we
was living in such Dark Ages we were so
IST in every regard that it is best not
to expose our fragile and now obtained
the highest plane Egos and psyches with
such works as were written before the
ancient era which Michelle hansworth be
referred to as all that which happened
before 2008.
um
that was good thank you I I don't think
that's what this is about oh you don't
no I don't um here's what I think this
is about okay is it is it just
Fahrenheit 451 in new form it it sort of
it comes down to trade-offs oh you will
not be surprised to discover
can I interrupt please
I forgot to read the very next paragraph
when it comes to disposing of the books
that are weeded the board documents say
the resources are causing harm either as
a health hazard because of the condition
of the book or because they're inclusive
culturally responsive relevant or
accurate for these reasons the documents
say the books cannot be donated as quote
they are not suitable for any learners
so this is book Burn
health hazard well no so moldy so like
one one of these musty ones unpleasant
refers to the actual physical condition
the book so books like is so wait a
second okay I leave open the possibility
that in our very broken world that
people's very broken immune systems may
be having a very broken reaction to the
moment but is there anything no there
there are books that are so far gone
that you really don't want anyone
reading them inhaling them yes grotesque
is there any demonstrated instance of a
measurable health impact of musty books
there's a lot of people with mold
toxicity right now but yes yeah I do
they have that mold toxicity that's fine
but that's a different question so I you
know I this it's not worth arguing that
there are no books that actually
shouldn't be destroyed because they
actually do pose a health hazard I am
certain that there are but it is not the
majority of this it's not 50 of the
books in you know individual libraries
in Canada it's talking about the
misinformation in the books the health
hazard yes that is yes
um I still want to know that anybody has
demonstrated a health hazard for books I
leave over the past right so you were
saying about uh trade-offs yeah
here's what it is
um
there is a harm to the empty shelves do
you have the picture of those empty
shelves uh let me see uh
there's one oh there was an emptier one
okay so that's one this is uh grade 10
student Reyna Takata took this photo of
the bookshelves in her Mississauga High
School libraries her first week back to
school this fall and then there's
another one there's a random yeah that
one's more unless empty I think they
have to do more work emptying them for
my point to be accurate but they'll get
there uh
here it is whose side are you on
the empty shelves
are a psychological health hazard to
people who grew up uh in the former
Soviet Union they will be traumatized by
the experience of seeing empty shelves
but students who live in the west will
now be prepared for the empty shelves
they're soon going to Face by going into
the library it's in training yeah yeah
we're helping you prepare for your
future that we are bringing you will eat
bugs have nothing to read and be happy
sorry that's terrible no it's I just I
tell them like it is honestly if I have
to choose between not having anything to
read and um
and eating bugs I'll eat the bugs you'll
eat the bugs yeah
you do you know there are a lot of bugs
and I know and I've had I've tried I've
tried bugs on three different occasions
I've never enjoyed it I don't want to
eat bugs but yeah um
if it's if it's that and and and no
you're like we're not we're not making
that choice this is this is like when I
said last week I think it was
um if I had to choose between cross sex
hormones and puberty blockers for my
children I would actually go with the
cross sex hormones both are awful
both outcomes are awful
um but
um you might with regard to you know
bugs and reading you might just have an
individual
um preference for actually which which
thing am I absolutely unwilling to give
up like do I know that my quality of
life would be so so unutterably changed
uh that would be very hard to to proceed
and um tell me I can't read ever again
well you're in luck because it is the
same morons I'm in luck because I've got
shelves and shelves and shelves of
actual real books yeah
um yeah but you're also in luck because
it's the same morons pushing all of this
stuff and so we just simply have no
choice but to fight back and win yes yes
we do okay let's do that fight back and
win fight back and win yep
all right that's an excellent plan
um okay let's fight back and win
so
um we're gonna be back next week we're
not gonna do a q a today uh we will be
back next week uh four hours later at 3
30 Pacific and we will therefore also
not be doing a q a next week because
we'll be getting started late
um please come join us on locals um
there's lots going on right now the chat
party is happening right now
um watch party watch party
um the guest episodes are released early
there we've got our monthly private q a
there
um you've done a couple of impromptu
amas there we're gonna be doing more and
and the questions were great hopefully
the answers were good but uh
excellent
um
yeah so please please join us there and
please subscribe to the rumble Channel
um on in Natural Selections this week I
um I was talking a bit about Narcan and
the fact that it is now available over
the counter this is of course in uh an
opioid overdose nasal spray that the FDA
has decided to make available over the
counter
you make it sound like
for the purpose of creating an overdose
that's a whole different drug that's not
what they say it's for but it does seem
to make the whole opioid crisis uh
anyway it's uh it's a classic Pharma
win-win yeah they win they win and they
win again yeah they they win from
causing the problem and then they win
from addressing the problem yeah and as
I as I say in this piece actually I mean
I also I've read about a number of
things
um
this week of Natural Selections but um
at the bottom of the Oregon Health
Authority blog post on this I mean wapo
New York Times and everyone's writing
about Narcan being available over the
counter now but the Oregon Health
Authority Post has at the bottom of this
post would which includes quotations
from this doctor was like in a perfect
world everyone would carrying our cats
like that's your perfect world amazing
wow am I glad you're not my doctor but
at the bottom of this post like further
recommended reading and one of the three
posts that are recommended reading is an
article from 2021 explaining why you
really should never ever ever take
ivermect unless you're a prescription
because that could be dangerous
that's recommended further reading on a
post for like fentanyl addicts who are
getting Narcan for neither of which do
they have prescriptions for I am quite
sure yeah and also Fentanyl and Narcan
not all that safer effective Narcan
apparently is effective but um not as
safe as the doctor interviewed says it
is an ibomechanism both
I digress um go check out Natural
Selections if you want to see more hear
more about that
um we have cool merchandise and we're
gonna have more we're gonna we're gonna
create some new stuff soon uh um at the
store but we got a lot of great stuff
now darkhorsestore.org
um print shop out of Louisville Kentucky
uh makes all of our stuff they're great
um
and
yeah once again check out our sponsors
this week which were armra paleo Valley
and uncruise
um all fantastic
and anything else to say
I think we're there I think we're there
all right until we see you next time
then be good to the ones you love eat
good food get outside
[Music]